foreign
the layoffs are out there we had this
huge
shortage of Labor kind of still do oh
yeah absolutely still do it's a weird
stagflation economy that we're in really
a shortage of Labor and yet a recession
is um blooming yep appears to be being
predicted the FED had asked for this
they're trying to cause it and I think
they're pulling it off so a lot of large
publicly traded companies are laying
people off last Monday night the night
before Thanksgiving uh United Furniture
makes Lane Furniture uh send an email to
all 2 700 workers at their Mississippi
plant and uh they went home on Monday
from work and got an email yeah or a
text saying they'll come back tomorrow
most woke up in the morning the email
went out late at night and woke up the
next morning you're done don't even come
in yeah Asurion here in Nashville has
laid off a couple thousand layoffs a
couple thousand people different times
uh Facebook has announced that the
company's gonna be laying off 11 000
employees 13 of its Workforce of course
musk laid off half of Twitter
for whatever reason uh 3 700 jobs there
Amazon laid off 10 000 workers marking
the largest job Cuts in the company's
history Rideshare company Lyft laid off
13 of its staff 700 workers earlier this
month fintech stripe announced it would
lay off 14 percent of its Workforce 1100
employees online real estate broker
Redfin laid off 862 workers about 13 of
his Workforce Salesforce the enterprise
software company uh cut hundreds of
workers last week and the company stock
has dropped about 38 percent in value
layoffs they are out there they are but
it is important to hear because you just
heard Dave walk through a list and the
media is playing this up big time
because it makes you click but you need
to understand something what is common
among that list and among the other
large layoffs over the last 90 days is
anticipation these companies are laying
people off in anticipation of a
recession most of these companies are
publicly held companies so they are
thinking about their stock price it's a
different game than small business in
America so what they will do is they
will hire up and staff up so you hear
Amazon laying off tens of thousands of
workers why let's just translate that
okay
public these publicly traded companies
are buttholes
okay because here's what they're doing
all right let me tell you why Salesforce
in their press release Salesforce said
they laid these people off to increase
profits that's exactly right it's about
the stock price simply increase in
profits and so I mean
what what that I mean so you didn't need
them when you hired them
you they weren't going to make you money
when you hired them
oh no no they were gonna make us money
but one way to increase profits is to
slash the payroll line on the p l
temporarily and it temporarily makes us
look like we're more profitable although
there's not people to do the work that
causes us to be more profitable later
that's correct so we rehired later and
so it's Corporate America being
buttholes all they're doing is they're
they're creating Pro false profit no kid
no pun intended I like that the false
prophet profit that didn't come from
generating revenues and doing a better
job profit that came from cutting and
expense that you actually needed and
Investments that you actually needed in
order to appear to be more profitable
that's right and they do that on the
backs of you
in America and some of you uh you're
really having the great regret because
some of you left a job with a company
that actually was a pretty good company
to make
15 or 20 more thousand dollars over a
publicly traded jerk wad bill that's
right and they told you you could work
from home and guess who got guess who
got laid off first at all these
companies all the all the research we're
seeing coming in the the number one the
two types of people that got laid off
the last one's hired and the ones that
are working from home that's correct
that's exactly right the data says that
that's not our opinion that's what the
data says and the reason you're out of
sight you're out of mind and Dave you're
absolutely right out of your mind that's
right you look at Amazon for instance so
Amazon it came out early this year an
internal Memo from one of their
Executives they were worried about being
able to actually hire people in multiple
cities of the US because they had burned
through available workers they treat
people like Commodities and Dave's
exactly right the minute that a
recession might be looming what do they
do it's about the almighty dollar and
the stock price and we're not against
capitalism we love it and I'm all for
profit but the fact of the matter is
Dave you're exactly right they begin to
just diminish people they go all right
you are just a number on a spreadsheet
we don't care about you it was all about
the stock price it's all about profit so
when consumers are buying I don't know I
announced our 1100 people last week that
our profits are down this year because
our costs are up
and as a result we are laying off
precisely no one
because we wouldn't have freaking hired
you in the first place if we didn't need
you
and I'm not going to put more money in
my pocket as the owner
and increase my profits by dumping you
in the street at the first sign of a
black cloud because I'm like a human and
I like other humans and treat them like
people not like robots that can be
thrown in the ditch the first time
something comes up that's right and
that's how small business operates by
and large you don't hear small
businesses going oh we're going to lay
people off so I can make more profit
yeah
people that own small businesses don't
do that and as a matter of fact right
now Dave small businesses are looking to
hire they can't find people to hire this
exact difference they're trying to grow
their business and Amazon and the big
public companies are trying to just grow
their stock price big difference so
Corporate America has always and and
this is not against capitalism by
Corporate America I mean big companies
with no heart no soul
and and some big companies have a heart
and soul some little companies don't
have a heart so but I'm talking when I'm
when I say Corporate America I mean
these companies that treat people they
treat the customer
like a unit of Revenue they treat so you
know you're a number when you're a
customer of Bank of America Bank of
America sucks
if you're a customer Bank of America you
know they couldn't care less whether you
live or die you are a number
it's all they care about as a customer
you're a unit of Revenue and by the way
if you work there you're a unit of
production and there's no Humanity in a
company like that none whatsoever now
there's again it's not based solely on
size but you guys know what I'm talking
about and so what this is is a warning
on behalf of the Ken Coleman movement to
get a job get a career make a move if
you want to make a move uh for more
money if you want to that's great I got
no issue with that for a better
opportunity for an area that's where you
are functioning in your sweet spot in
your purpose yeah but don't be going
solely based on money I'm gonna hold my
nose and move over to some company that
has a value system that I can't stand
they're so woke I can't sleep that's
right and I don't want to be around
these people and you're going to run
over there and jump in the middle of
that septic tank and hold your nose and
hope you don't get screwed well of
course you're going to get screwed
that's exactly right here's what happens
the paycheck and the promotion wear off
when you the person know that you're in
the wrong pool you just know it's not
right it will eat away at you your soul
will slowly slip out of your body where
you work matters yep so here's the thing
do sometimes companies reach a point
that they are not profitable or are
approaching that and have to as a
mathematical necessity let people go
yeah we were facing that potentially
during covet we didn't know what we were
going to have I mean we had in we had
tens of millions of dollars of Revenue
in certain areas like for instance doing
Live Events you remember when you
stopped doing that suddenly remember
when I canceled a cruise in the middle
of March of 2020 yeah that was handy uh
so when the revenue just evaporates
and there's no money
then you can't pay people then you've
got to lay them off but then and but but
there's a couple things that go with
that uh this is not this is not laying
people off just to increase your profits
which is about as
Corporate America as it gets okay so
there's a couple things that go with
this these problems number one
the
Factory in Mississippi laying off 2700
the the duper from better give me a
break uh laying people off from Zoom
from his kitchen table suddenly with no
warning those two had shared one thing
in common they knew they were in trouble
oh a long time before they laid those
people off that's correct so you owe
your team
information that's accurate yeah
well they might leave
dumb butt you're getting ready to lay
them off okay I mean seriously of course
they might leave because
you're announcing that the ship is
taking on water we think we can stay
afloat but uh we got a leak over here
and you go ahead and tell these guys
it's like months before because you know
it months before yeah you know what's
going on and so number one lots and lots
and lots of clear
open authentic communication early and
often this is what you do if you're a
real leader in a company regardless of
the size of the company and and then the
second thing
is you do not lay people off in order to
line your own pockets
these are people that have lives they
have kids and dogs and
husbands and wives and college funds and
I mean you don't build your personal
fortune on the backs of laying people
off that trusted you by coming to work
for you
that's morally wrong that's right okay
that's just that's wrong and so you know
it's not it's not a legal issue at all
but a you need to give them notice lots
and lots of open communication lots of
notice B do sometimes then you actually
have to do this because it's an
arithmetic thing yeah yeah that's right
sometimes you have to and then uh you
should
feel it yeah going through a zoom call
that's right it's dignity it's the
difference between I'm on a zoom and I
had no warning and all of a sudden bam
I'm not sitting there with my leader
able to process information and ask
questions I've just been hit right in
the forehead and there's nothing I can
do about it